have you got bad credit
well Amazon has a solution for you their
new credit card helps you get into debt
with your own money this is from Fast
Company the e-commerce giant has a new
store credit card targeted at people
with less-than-perfect credit scores in
partnership with synchrony Bank the
Amazon Prime store credit card builder
lets people put down a refundable
security deposit yep like an apartment
which will be used to set the cards
total credit limit synchrony will then
collect that deposit from you and give
you a line of credit loaning you your
own money back from there people can
spend their own money that they loan to
the bank and then borrowed it back at
amazon.com using their new credit card
from money that they put up depending on
how much money they spend on the card
the users get 6 12 or 24 months of no
interest for their own money if people
spend less than hundred and forty-nine
dollars on the card they're not eligible
for this promotional financing and the
cards APR is 28.24 percent that you're
paying to borrow your own money cash
Amazon what would we do without a
company like you to help us out
unbelievable according to wallet hub the
average interest rate for people with
fair credit is twenty-two point nine
nine percent these are stupid people too
and the average store credit card has
interest rates of twenty five point
seven six percent but the credit builder
card though it's twenty eight point two
four percent of your own money yeah this
is all part of Amazon's plan to own the
world I mean part of Amazon's plan to
bring anyone and everyone into its
credit program it's essentially a
subprime credit card option that
mitigates the risk for Amazon you're
kidding really you mean if I give you
enough money to cover the money you're
gonna loan me back it mitigates your
risk where did you no no of course it
does no kidding
they only stand to rake in fees and
interest once the promotional period is
over which of course is why they're
doing this which is to say it's another
way for corporations to make money off
of poor people while creating a pathway
for them to spend more money
well the prepaid credit card the secured
credit card the prepaid debit card have
always been out there most the time
though they're not associated with a 28%
rate where are you borrowing your own
money back you're pretty freaking
desperate
by the way Amazon will take a debit card
I know because I buy stuff on Amazon I'm
a costumer really not mad at Amazon
they're so dadgum big that they just
didn't know that there was stupid people
working in one corner of the
organization they were trying this crap
so 16 million people just got told
Amazon that you suck on this product
people are laughing all over America
right now at the absurdity of this as I
said this out loud people who use that
was on prime every day or laughing at
you right now Amazon really bad PR move
screw your customers so it's never a
good thing it never works out if you
just help people which is what you've
done Amazon for years I mean we're a big
customer of their tech services AWS as
well not mad at Amazon the company
they're too big to be mad at because not
not because I'm scared of them but just
because they're just the right end
doesn't know what the left hand is doing
the people over in the media side are
great people we do work with them all
the time their book selling people are
by and large great people we do work
with them all the time I'm a customer I
buy stuff on there you know click Amazon
Prime I want your stuff delivered to my
door just like you so it's it overall is
a great company and they're always
trying something new so you got to get
them that - they're constantly trying
something new they're constantly
iterating that's good it's a good
business model look at but this is about
idea boys and girls yes shouldn't launch
this one and so whoever's working on
this stuff y'all and y'all need to reset
your brain and to
synchrony bank to go somewhere else to
screw someone else's customers not yours
because that's what you're doing when
you give someone a thousand dollars so
that you can borrow a thousand dollars
on a credit card at 28% and you call
that credit car a credit card credit or
the store card credit builder can him
say it it's so stupid
so you'll earn them a thousand dollars
and then they let you borrow your
thousand dollars back at twenty eight
percent you're stupid and they're
screwing you and it's your fault and
their fault gosh I hope I wasn't unclear
was that pretty clear about that okay
just making sure everybody knows all
right because I you know there's plenty
of stuff out there I mean you know you
look at some of the stupid but stuff
that city bank does or Fifth Third does
or Bank of America god help you if you
bank with Wells Fargo
they fired twenty four thousand
employees for fraud who even has twenty
four thousand employees much less fire
that many for fraud and stay open after
that yeah and it just kind of went under
the radar nobody talked about it much
but you know they did so this is what
you're dealing with when you're dealing
with a big bank corporate America crap
because they just they have one goal get
your money that's their goal and you go
in there like sheep to a slaughter
thinking that they are there to help you
their stated goal at these banks is
increase shareholder profits you know
how they do that
they take your money that's how they do
that so this really isn't rocket science
you guys you have to be wise consumers
you have to not fall for stuff like this
and this is not a service to poor people
please how many times people screw poor
people and act like and then they say
well we're a service to poor people they
they don't have access to credit
otherwise you know it's just
unbelievable it's unbelievable you know
and you just you should not screw poor
people and call it a good
practice opressing the poor is not a
list of things you want to be on when
God looks at your list okay dumb and you
go serving them yeah well listen when
you take 28% out of their hide you ain't
serving them anymore at that point
you've been served
okay that's what's going on give me a
break
so Amazon and AD move boys and girls a
little o synchrony Bank you thought
you'd landed a whale with Amazon didn't
you and then along comes a consumer
advocate me calling you out and
reminding consumers to stay clear of
this never put up money to secure a
credit card so you have the opportunity
to borrow your own money back and pay
them interest because you're so freakin
desperate to rebuild your credit for the
opportunity to go in debt again this is
just stacking stupid on stupid people